Vy la grève dans la fonction publique a
été plutôt bien suivie des perturbations
dans toutes les grandes villes de France
les fonctionnaires manifestaient
aujourd'hui pour le maintien de leur
pouvoir d'achat neuf blessés dont deux
assez gravement c'est le bilan de la
raisonnement hier de deux chalutiers
espagnol par la marine française les
pêcheurs espagnols opérent sans licence
au large des côtes de La Rochelle
en France peut-être bientôt dans
l'espace la France peut-être bientôt
dans l'espace au côté des Américains le
patron de la NASA était reçu cet
après-midi à l'Élysée il propose à la
France de participer à un projet d'usine
de l'espace enfin il y avait une soirée
de Coupe d'Europe de football hier soir
la Juventus s'est qualifié in extrémist
face au Finlandais dans ce journal les
plus beaux buts de cette
soirée mesdames messieurs bonsoir les
Français avaient bien des soucis pour se
déplacer aujourd'hui c'était lap
conséquence de la greffe des
fonctionnaires qui se déroulaient dans
toute la France elle touchait notamment
les transports les écoles l'électricité
et le gaz de France une grève appelée
par 5 des SEP fédérations de la fonction
publique puisque ni la CFDT ni la CFTC
ne s'y était associé un mouvement
apparemment assez bien suivi nous le
verrons tout à l'heure mais auparavant
je vous propose de passer en revue les
principales manifestations et les
réactions enregistrées ce matin par
Laurent
Carenzo à l'appel de la CGT de la FEN et
de la Fédération autonome les
fonctionnaires étaient dans la rue ce
matin à Paris 15000 personnes selon la
préfecture de police 15000 selon les
organisateurs un seul thème à cette
manifestation la défense du pouvoir
d'achat la plupart des organisations de
fonctionnaires estime en effet que le
manque à gagné varie entre 2500 et 5000
francs pour 1982 83 bien que la CFDT
n'est pas appelée à la grève ont trouvé
dans le défilé de nombreux adhérents de
la centrale d'ideemm dans l'ensemble la
plupart des slogan exprimer une forte
opposition à la politique salariale du
gouvernement est-ce que vous pensez que
le mécontentement peut s'amplifier dans
les semaines qui viennent il existe ce
mécontentement il s'est amplifié au
cours de la période écoulée et
logiquement si les choses devaient
continuer ainsi pour des raisons
diverses il il s'amplifiera encore
comment voulez-vous que les gens soient
contents si le pouvoir d'achat continue
à diminuer si le nombre de chemirue à
augmenter ils sont forcément mécontents
et c'est notre rôle de syndicat d'être
avec eux d'organiser l'action pour qu'il
en soit autrement parce qu'il est
possible de faire tout à fait autre
chose et de faire mieux et nous ne
renonçons pas à réussir à faire que les
choses aillent mieux mais pour ça il est
bon que les travailleurs se fassent
entendre s'il y en a qui pensaient que
ça pouvait
s'arranger comme ça attendre que ça
vienne et bien les événements se sont
chargés de leur rappeler que personne ne
fera le bonheur des travailleurs à leur
place et que bah quand ça va pas il faut
se faire
entendre les adhérents de forces
ouvrières de leur côté avaient décidé de
se faire entendre à la Bourse du Travail
pour ne pas défiler au côté de la CGT la
centrale d'André Bergeron bien implantée
chez les fonctionnaires rejeté comme
toutes les autres organisations
l'accusation d'avoir déclenché une grève
politique grève politique là encore je
me permets simplement de sourire car
s'il y a bien une grève qui me paraît
normale c'est celle qui a été organisé
pour la défense du pouvoir d'achat
d'ailleurs ces millions de
fonctionnaires
qui ont manifesté aujourd'hui leur
opposition à la politique actuelle vous
le savez aussi bien que moi dans leur
très grande majorité on Sansen doute
voter pour la gauche en
1981 donc il ne s'agit sûrement pas
d'une grffe politique je crois que c'est
un coup de Semon sérieux qui est adressé
au Gouvernement qui ne respecte pas la
parole qui a été donnée et sur ce point
nous espérons que ce coup de Semon sera
entendu il ressort que globalement je
dis bien
globalement en masse salariale
distribuée il y a un retard de la masse
des salaires versés aux fonctionnaires
en 82 et 83 par rapport à ce qu'ils
auraient dû obtenir si cette masse avait
évoluer comme les prix de
0,52
%. Aniss le port reconnaît donc que le
pouvoir d'achat a subi une diminution
ces deux dernières années mais pour le
moment la prime de 500 francs et
l'augmentation de 1%
suff pas au fonctionnair rien n'est
réglé mais la porte reste ouverte
négociation et grogne devra donc se
poursuivre de concert dans les semaines
qui
viennent cette grve a été assez
diversement suivi selon les secteurs et
ce sont les transports qui ont été le
plus touchés par le mouvement avec Lauro
maintenant la physionomie de cette
journée on rla au ralenti sur plusies
auourd'hui au he de
pointe dans la matinée il n'y avait que
30 à 40% de RAM de métro en circulation
davantage 75% sur les liges A B du R
moins sur les
autres très peu d'autobus de conducteurs
sur TR é en grève à la RP la CFDT sétait
join au
mouvementcon la direction le mouvement é
très bien suivi dans tous les secteurs
dans la banli parisien se un train sur 3
à un TR sur 5 circul sur les grandes
lignes un TR sur
4 dans les air air France estime que
deux moyens courriers sur trois et un
long courrier sur trois sont restés au
sol en plus aucun avion n'a pu décoller
d'orli et roissi entre 8h du matin et
midi en raison de la greffe des
contrôleurs de la navigation aérienne
pour ce qui est de l'EDF on a relevé des
coupures de courant sur tout le
territoire entre 10h et MIDH et un
retour à la normale ensuite la greffe
des enseignants a été suivie à près de
40 % selon le ministère à 70 % selon la
feine des classes ont été annulées dans
de nombreuses écoles mais la garde des
enfant enfant était assuré dans les PTT
aussi le mouvement a été suivi les
bureaux de poste invité à ne pas déposer
de courrier et le courrier ne fut pas
distribué non plus une lettre qui devra
attendre
demain voilà pour le bilan disons
technique de cette grève nationale des
fonctionnaires reste maintenant
l'analyse politique de ce mouvement
alors vous savez qu'on a beaucoup
insisté ces derniers jours sur le fait
qu'il s'agissait de la première greffe
générale dans la fonction publicque
depuis mai 1980 il faut bien reconnaître
que ce mouvement crée quelqu embarras
pour le gouvernement d'autant qu'il
vient conclure un mois social difficile
après la greffe des routiers et la
grande manifestation de Versailles pour
l'enseignement privé paulamar bien le
gouvernement est entré dans une zone de
turbulence il s'y attendait d'ailleurs
la secouse d'aujourd'hui semble moins
importante que les précédentes les
routiers ou versaill c'était plus
spectaculaire mais elle peut avoir pour
la gauche des séquelles plus graves les
fonctionnaires qui ont défilé
aujourd'hui avaient en effet pour la
plupart voté pour François miteran
contrairement aux manifestants de
Versailles et c'est la première fois
depuis 81 qu'ils sont aussi nombreux a
protesté contre la politique du pouvoir
de leur patron comme dit Jacques pomato
le numéro 1 de la feine un patron qu'ils
ont choisi qu'ils ont élu et qui leur
est donc dans une certaine mesure du
moins le pense-t-il redevable quel
dilemme pour ce patron ou bien il leur
donne satisfaction il respecte ainsi le
contrat politique mais il prend un
risque économique tout son édifice bâti
sur la lutte contre l'inflation donc sur
une faible augmentation des salaires
peut s'écrouler ou bien il ne cède pas
au nom de la rigueur et c'est l'édifice
politique autrement dit la majorité qui
peut Sém
le Parti communiste et certains
socialistes conjurent François mitteran
d'opter pour la première solution mais
le président de la République restera
semble-t-il déterminé il a décidé
d'abord d'assaainir et de relancer
l'économie et il compte sur l'efficacité
de cette remise en ordre pour convaincre
les Français aujourd'hui hostiles ou
perplexes mais ce Paris ne réussira que
si l'éclairci apparaît avant le grand
rendez-vous du septena avant l'élection
législative de
86 l'actualité sociale toujours avec
l'annonce de près de 6000 suppressions
d'emploi chez Citroën c'est ce que la
direction devrait annoncer demain au
comité central d'entreprise sur ce
sureffectif de 5959 employés plus de
3000 partirai en
pré-retraite la raisonnement de deux
chalutier espagnol au large de la
Rochelle c'est le second titre de ce
journal il ne s'agirait que d'un
incident tout à fait banal si la marine
française n'avait pas été amené à tirer
pour contraindre les pêcheurs espagnols
d'obéir il se trouvait en effet dans une
zone où il n'avait pas le droit de jeter
leur filets les bâtiments français ont
tiré des coups de semonce mais qui ont
quand même fait neuf blessés dont deux
assez gravement
attins les deux bateaux espagnols à
raésonnés hier au large de la Rochelle
étaient des récidivistes ils avaient
l'habitude de pêcher le merlu dans la
zone économique des 200000 sans licence
le Vallet des accondour était à sa 7e
infraction et son deuxè délit de fuite
le Burgoa Mandi immatriculé à
Saint-Sébastien et arrivé ce matin
lorrient avait déjà commis 11
infractions et un délit de fuite son
patron sera poursuivi pour les mêmes
motifs que par le passé est condamné
probablement à une forte amende mais ses
risques il les accepte à chaque
marée on se rend compte maintenant qu'on
a eu très peur parce qu'on ne pensait
vraiment pas que la marine allait tirer
avec une canonnière en plus oui ça ça
nous a fait très
peur je pense que nous continuerons à
pêcher dans ces eau et je ne crois pas
que les Français s'amuseront à tirer une
seconde fois onut sarrê de pêcher dans
cette zone nos ancêtres ont toujours
travaillé dans le golfe de Gascogne ça
fait partie de nos traditions oui je
pense vraiment qu'on a le droit de
pêcher
ici les pêches illégales de bateaux
espagnols dans la zone économique se
multiplient au fur et à mesure que
Bruxelles diminue le nombre de licen
pour la flotle espagnol depuis le 1er
janvier 200 chalutiers en situation
irrégulière ont été repérés dans le Gol
de Gascogne les incidents entre la
marine les affaires maritimes et les
récal Citran sont fréquents la
raisonnement par contrainte devient une
procédure courante hier il a fallu 5
heur d'intervention pour stopper les
deux chalutiers espagnol n'ont pas n'ont
pas du tout obéi à cette injonction
puisqueau contraire ils sont partis à ce
moment-là le il y a eu un coup de Semon
avec un projectile inerte qui était tiré
largement sur l'avant des navires de
pêche
espagnol environ 300 m sur l'avant et
les Espagnols n'ont pas du tout réagi
non plus ils ont continué à s'enfuir à
moment là le ils sont devenus au
contraire beaucoup plus agressifs et il
y a eu semble-t-il des tentatives
d'abordage sur le lieutenant de vaisseau
la vallée et sur le remorqueur de haute
mer à ce moment-là un obus a été tiré
sur l'avant du navire sur lequel il n'y
avait personne et cet OBU a a fait
éclater un peu de bois et de métal et
ces éclats de bois et de métal ont
blessé neu personnes sur ce chalutier
c'est le Vallet des hundo qui a pris la
décision de tirer sur le bateau sur le
chalutier la décision ét prise au plus
haut niveau au niveau ministériel au
niveau du ministère du ministère de la
mer et de la et de la défense 10 années
les Européens ont baissé de 30 % leur
capacité de pêche pratiquement les
Anglais ont perdu la moitié de leur
flotte pendant le même temps les
Espagnols ont augmenté de près de 50 %
leur capacité de pêche c'està dire que
l'effort qui a été fait au niveau de
l'Europe n'a pas été fait au niveau de
l'Espagne pour des raisons que je n'ai
pas analysé mais il apparaît que tous
ces pêcheurs espagnols en surnombre
cherchent à pêcher dans le territoire
européen que les Européens avec de
grands sacrifices essayent de préserver
alors il n'est pas question j'ajoute
bien de les empêcher d'aller pêcher il
est question de limiter leur action de
pêche et le gouvernement espagnol a
signé avec la communauté un accord
disant et bien l'effort de pêche se
limitera à tant de licence mais le drame
c'est que si on donne un certain nombre
de licences on trouve deux fois plus de
bateaux sur les lieux de
pêche aujourd'hui l'ambassadeur
d'Espagne s'est immédiatement rendu
auprès des neuf marins pêcheurs
espagnols hospitalisés à l'Orient deux
seulement sont assez gravement atteints
par des éclats de bois aux
jambes cet incident n'est pas tout à
fait une surprise puisque 2700
chalutiers notamment espagnols ont déjà
été surpris en train de pêcher dans les
zones économiques françaises et
communautaires depuis le 1er janvier
1980 dans certains cas la Marine
nationale a pu arrisonner les bateaux de
pêche et une trentaine d'incidents se
sont déjà produits pourtant en dehors de
de quelques orionion il n'y avait jamais
eu de véritables blessés reste que les
pêcheurs français du Pays-Basque
s'attendaient à une bavure un jour ou
l'autre Dominique
tiersce sur le port de Sibourg l'action
de la Marine nationale a largement été
commentée ce matin après la criée ici
les chalutiers espagnols et français
sont tous les jours face à face les
pêcheurs espagnols ratissent les eaux
communautaires sans licence et ce sans
que personne ne puisse les en empêcher
cela fait des années que les pêcheurs
basques voient les garde-côtes
intervenir mais les incursions
continuent et et les bateaux espagnol
sont de plus en plus
nombreux pe rien faire contre ce que
vous racontez c'est presque comme une
petite Guer dans le
golfci toujours puis il sont en
force on peut rien faireil a ch on
dégage c'est
tout très rich il vient pêcher e e
français Paso norm pas voustes pour la
solution de
for pour qu'on puisse travailler
tranquille ouais parce qu'il se cent
permis de tout
puis on peut rien faire quoi s'ils
veulent manger ils sont obligés de venir
ici et pourquoi pour ils ont tout ravagé
chez
eux alors ils viennent ici maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il ramasse comme poisson
eux de tout tout il cherch ils cherch ce
qui est nous on a une taille marchande
qu'on respecte euh chez nous on respecte
la taille marchande il la respecte même
pas alors pour respecte les règles ement
les pêcheurs de siibour aujourd'hui même
ont rejeté 6 tonnes de sardines qui
n'avaient pas la taille requise
habituellement les Espagnols ne le font
pas et c'est bien aussi ce qu'on leur
reproche la presse espagnole condamne
très sévèrement l'action de la marine
française qui est comparée là-bas à un
acte de guerre les journaux madrilennes
relèvent par ailleurs que cette action
pourrait avoir de très graves
répercussions sur les relations entre
Paris et Madrid le ministre des Affaires
étrangères espagnoles monsieur Fernando
Moran a néanmoins tenté tout à l'heure
d'apaiser les passions c'était dans an
de les rapports entre l'Espagne et la
France les relations sont très important
aussi bien pour la France que pour
l'Espagne alors ça sera enludant de ma
part de tirer des conséquences
maintenant mais seulement je vais faire
de l'importance c'est la gravité que le
gouvernement
espagnol considèr s laquelle g espagnol
considère les événements mais vous
considérez que l'incident est aussi
grave que cela question sérieuse et
grave et il faut et bien je vous écoute
oui on vous prête aussi l'intention de
rappeler votre ambassadeur à Paris non
je ne trouve pas que ce soit des
questions qui se posent non je ne crois
pas il faut voir quand même les dossiers
mais je ne crois pas nous avons la
volonté d'avoir des bons rapports avec
la France par des raisons évidentes mais
nous sommes très fermes pour juger ces
procédés et nous souhaitons qu'il
s'arêpte pas et s'il y a une explication
satisfais du côté de la France elle sera
la
bienvenue il faut ajouter à cela que le
chef de l'opposition espagnole a suggéré
ce matin d'ajourner la visite que Pierre
MAOI doit faire demain à Madrid en la
qualifiant de totalement inopportune
monsieur Maroi doit en effet se rendre
en visite privée demain en Espagne dans
le cadre de l'association des villes
jumelées alors cet incident survenu dans
le golfe de Gascogne met en relief les
véritables problèmes que pose le
contrôle des eaux françaises et
communautaires c'est à la marine
national qu'il revient de faire
respecter les règlements dans la zone
des 200000 à partir de nos côtes mais il
est très exceptionnel que des vedettes
des affaires maritime ou des bâtiments
de la Marine nationale en soit réduit à
faire des tirs de semonce Jean-Claude
darigot nous explique maintenant de quel
moyen dispose la marine pour effectuer
ses contrôles
8h30 base aérienne de landyway départ de
la première patrouille de surveillance
des zones maritimes d'intérêt
économique les vols se succéderont dans
la journée assurés alternativement par
la Marine nationale et les services des
Douine le but de ces opérations
surveiller les mouvements des navires de
pêche sur le front Atlantique des côtes
françaises devenu par le biais des
accords communautaires patrimoine de
l'Europe des 10 sont chez eux ici tous
les chalutiers de la Communauté
européenne restent donc à suivre de près
les
autres un chalutier espagnol a été
repéré il n'appartient pas à la flotte
de pêche des 10 une demande radio est
envoyée au service informatique de
contrôle des affaires maritimes qui vont
en quelques instant déterminer si oui ou
non le navire peut opérer dans le
secteur ok bien reçu le si 12 226 je
contrôle alors c'est
le 12
ou al le chtier que vous m'avez demandé
de contrôler
leag
jus3 l'action conjointe va se poursuivre
pendant plusieurs heures avec repè et
graphi de
progression communauté peut dans
certaine mesure admettre que des
pays tiers puissent envoyer leurs
navires pêcher dans les eaux
communautaire à condition qu'il
n'exagère pas à la condition bien sûr
qu'il respecte les normes fixées par la
communauté qui sont des normes de nombre
de navires autorisés à pêcher
deuxièmement des normes de tonnage total
admissible à un pavillon dans une zone
déterminée et 3oisièmement des mesures
techniques type maillage à respecter
espèces autorisées ou non autoris
et encore taille marchande minimale de C
de poisson quel pourcentage d'infraction
trouvez-vous en général pendant vos
missions aujourd'hui vous voyez nous
avons relevé une infraction sur trois
navires observés il faut penser que dans
le temps les infractions relevées sont
se situe entre 10 et voire jusqu'à 50
%. les éventuels procèsverbaux
d'infraction et les amendes sont
transmis au bateau concerné par le biais
de la Commission de Bruxelles cette
procédure normale et sans esclandre
fonctionne bien pour la plupart des
navires n'appartenant pas à la CEE elle
n'a pas découragé les récidives de
certains chalutiers espagnols qui ont
créé également des problèmes au large de
la Grande-Bretagne et de plusieurs
autres pays de la
communauté en Espagne on dénonce donc je
vous le disait la brutalité de la
réaction française mais c'est chez les
pêcheurs espagnols ce la même qui
viennent pêcher près de nos côtes avec
ou sans autorisation c'est parmi eux que
la colère est la plus manifeste Daniel
lecte le port d'ondor cet après-midi
l'ambiance est grave sur les quais où
l'on commmente les événements survenus
la veille nous sommes en terre espagnool
tout le monde connait ici les victimes
et tout le monde partage leur malheurs
nous arrivons alors que les pêcheurs
viennent d'apprendre qu'un des leurs
pourrait être amputé de la jambe
l'ambiance est plutôt mauvaise pour tout
dire elle est même franchement agressive
nous méritons une bonde sous les voiture
disent les uns pendant que d'autres
menacent de nous jeter dans le
port tout ça n'est pas bien de la part
d'une nation comme la France ce n'est
pas
correct passer les premières réactions
de violence les pêcheurs exposent alors
leurs problèmes des problèmes réels sans
aucun doute des EAU territoriales peu
poissonneuses alors que les artisans
pêcheurs ici sont 10 fois plus nombreux
que de l'autre côté du côté français
alors surtout que le règlement
communautaire européen leur interdit
désormais de pêcher sans licence dans
des EAU où jusque-là il se déplaçaient
librement ce qui a conduit de nombreux
artisans a
fermé certains acceptent la règle du jeu
mais d'autres ne l'acceptent pas mais
même parmi ceux qui ne l'acceptent pas
les pêcheurs d'ondaroa ont sinistre
réputation ici même au Pays-Basque
espagnol ont dit d'ux qu'ils n'ont pas
un abord très facile d'ailleurs avant
même que les événements se produisent un
pêcheur basque espagnol ne déclarait-il
pas à onaroa ce sont les pêcheurs et les
armateurs qui font la lo ce sont des
pirates si on les laissait faire il
viendrait prendre la cathédrale de
Bayonne voilà donc ce que l'on pouvait
dire ce soir sur ce dossier de la pêche
après l'arraisonnement hier donc de deux
chalutiers espagnols par la Marine
nationale française le reste de
l'actualité maintenant avec d'abord un
attentat dans un bar parisien de
menilmant c'est une valise piégée qui
aurait explosé faisant un blessé grave
et trois autres légèrement atteints
c'est le groupe d'extrême droite Charles
Martel qui a revendiqué l'attentat
une nouvelle inculpation pour crime
contre l'humanité à l'encontre de
Maurice Papon l'ancien ministre qui
était secrétaire général de la
préfecture de la Gironde pendant la
guerre monsieur Papon a été inculpé par
un juge d'instruction du tribunal de
Bordeaux et cela après le dépôt de 17
nouvelles plaintte comme lors de sa
précédente acculpation monsieur Papon a
déposé à son tour des plaintes pour
dénonciation calomnieuses contre ceux
qui l'attaquent ainsi en
justice un nouveau cas à Paris contre
une agence de la Société générale les
gangster ont vidé plusieurs dizaines de
coffres en plein jour c'est devenu
maintenant presque une habitude puisque
c'est la troisième fois cette semaine
qu'il pratique de la sorte Bruno
ledref toujours le même scénario 6 ou h
gangsters portant fausse barbe et fausse
moustache c'est bien le gang des
postiches qui a opéré cet après-midi à
l'agence de la Société Générale rue
Manin dans le 19e les malfaiteurs sont
rentrés dans la banque grimmé et masqué
clients et employés ont été conduits au
sous-sol et pendant 1 he et
onfes
de les gangst sont avec dans le bagage
le film de la caméra aucune trace c'est
leur 3e holdup depuis le début du mois
le 2 mars rue d'alisia le 6 mars rue de
Passi et aujourd'hui rue Manin en tout
250 coffres ouvert et sans violence une
facilité qui étonne les
policiers le directeur de la NASA James
B s'était cet après-midi à l'Élysée et
ce n'était pas une simple visite de
courtoisie qu'il rendait au chef de
l'État il venait l'entretenir d'un
projet que nourrit son organisation il
s'agit d'une usine de l'espace c'est du
moins ce que souhaite le président Rean
une usine de l'espace à la con de
laquelle les Américains aimeraient
intéresser l'Europe et surtout la France
les explications de Patrick
ester une image tout droit sortie d'un
film de science-fiction elle a pourtant
été calculée par des ingénieurs du plus
haut niveau cet engin tournera autour de
la Terre d'ici 10 ans un programme de 72
milliards de francs deux fois plus que
les voyages sur la lune pour construire
cette station quatre navettes
américaines emporteront dans leur sout
des modules habitables qui seront
assemblés directement dans l'espace à
350 km d'altitude grâce au bras de la
navette mais aussi à ces fameux sacade à
réaction les astronautes se
transformeront alors en mécanicien du
cosmos dès 1992 une petite dizaine
d'hommes habitera en permanence à bord
de l'engin cette équipe sera relayée
tous les 3
mois déjà dans cette grande piscine de
simulation de la NASA une cinquantaine
d'astronautes s'entraînent à Assem les
Prelles métalliques de la charpente de
cette station un système si complexe et
si cher qu'aujourd'hui les États-Unis
demandent au pays d'Europe d'apporter
leur contribution financière et
technique ils peuvent s'ils le
souhaitent participer au développement à
la fabrication et à l'utilisation de
cette
station nous espérons que quand elle
sera opérationnelle
elle offrira à toutes les nations
concernées une possibilité
exceptionnelle de travail scientifique
industriel et de recherche de pointe
dans
l'espace mais cet engin sera-t-il
uniquement scientifique ou bien
servira-t-il aussi au militaires
américains qui pourrait y installer à
long terme des systèmes de guidage
d'armes à laser ou à particules une idée
qui chemine déjà en Europe que l'Europe
soit capable de lancer dans l'espace une
station habitée qui lui permettra
d'observer de transmettre donc de
contrarier toute menace éventuelle et
elle aura fait un grand pas faire sa
propre
défense mais l'Europe pourra-t-elle
financer deux projets différents la
chose est peu probable les gouvernements
devront choisir une lourde
décision vivent les femmes ce pourrait
être le titre générique de cette journée
du jeudi 8 mars consacrée dans le monde
entier au droit de la femme le président
de la République recevra d'ailleurs
demain une délégation conduite par
Ivette roui à l'occasion de cette
journée internationale des femmes alors
je ne sais pas s'il faut faire un
rapport entre la journée des femmes et
cette information que je vous livre tel
quel mais le ministre de la Défense
Monsieur Charles Hernu vient de décider
d'accroître le nombre de femmes dans la
gendarmerie d'ailleurs ce cette journée
des femmes ce sera le thème du débat
dans notre dernier journal face- à face
Giselle animi qui est député du Parti
socialiste et Monique Pelletier qui est
ancien
ministre le sport maintenant jouet hier
soir les quarts de finale allé de la
Coupe d'Europe des Clubs le match vet
c'était sans conteste la rencontre entre
la Juventus de Turin et les finlandais
les finlandais qui ont d'ailleurs manqué
créer la surprise avant que les hommes
de Michel Platini ne se ressaisissent
voici les principaux buts de cette
soirée avec Roger Zabel l'idéal en Coupe
d'Europe est de ne pas encaisser de buts
sur son terrain les Autrichiens du
rapide de Vienne ont connu cette
mésaventure le Dynamo de Berlin a ouvert
la marque mais c'est Hamer qui égalise
pour une belle tête c'est une belle tête
et et crch donnera la victoire aux
Autrichiens 3 minutes avant la fin de la
rencontre juste juste la victoire des
Reds de Liverpool les champions
d'Angleterre juste un but mais quel but
un centre de la gauche de Kennedy et
tête au deè poteau du Galois Yan rush ça
décoiffe et au ralenti c'est encore plus
beau encore plus
vioire de la Juventus à Strasbourg
devant les amateurs finlandais de
AK avec à l'origine du unique Michel et
la
conclusion matchetour qui s'annonce
difficile pour l'équipe de Porto qui
arrache la victoire grâce à jacqu à la
minute
bonne opération pour barceloneamp
Maradona est sorti et à la dernière
minute c'est qui va conclure avec ce
petit tot à Bruxelles don pour le du
tré grce
à Ren c'est encore plus
encore plus juste la victoire de la
Juventus à Strasbourg devant les
amateurs finlandais de AK voch avec à
l'origine du SE et unique but Michel
Platini et à la
conclusion un match retour qui s'annonce
difficile pour l'équipe de Porto qui
arrache la victoire grâce à Jacques à la
B opération pour Barcelone Maradona est
s la dernière
minute con
avec to à Brell don pour le du
TR sur
grce
aucun problème pour Tottenham devant
l'Austria qui avait éliminé l'aval avec
prier après
minut me
anglaiv
plusardre aprs
personnel de
bras
au pas de course maintenant la météo
avec Alain gilop Pétré il y a les
petites fleurs qui poussent il y a le
gazon qui verd le problème c'est que
l'hiver continue regardez la carte de
demain on croit que tout va bien il y a
du soleil partout un peu de nuag sur les
Ases maisen voilà il y a aussi des
nuages beaucoup plus importants par le
NordOuest nord-ouest qui apporteront
quelques pluie ou neige intermittente en
s'enfonçant très très très très
lentement vers le sud c'est la situation
en milieu de journée cô des températures
encore dégelé cette nuit -1 - 2 - 4 et
l'après-midi de 8 à 10°gr sur la moitié
nord et de 8 à 16°gr sur la moitié sud
un joli tir groupé à 16 à 16°gr autour
de la Méditerranée demain vendredi 9
mars 4 minutes de soleil en plus à Paris
levé 7h16 couché 18h47 c'est la sainte
Françoise Romaine heureusement qu'on a
fait la journée des femmes aujourd'hui
parce que demain sainte Françoise
Romaine c'est la patronne des veuves ça
laffiche mal il est temps de refermer ce
journal vous avez rendez-vous à 23h10
avec HERV Claude pour les toutes
dernières informations je vous retrouve
demain soir à 20h
bonsoir